these comics yeah not so fast Barry
Allen not so fast character we're giving
both names for because then you'll know
he's the future flash and have a baby
nerd chubby for a couple minutes
also this movie opened with Barry
running for a solid ten seconds and yet
he's only about five feet away from the
broken-down car there's a gas station
also it's completely abandoned also it's
probably something you pass just before
he broke down the cool thing is like a
half mile away and why wasn't that the
first place you thought to go for help
rather than trying to run down that car
minute ago ah apparently every superhero
was created from dead mom energy also if
anyone knows the DC Universe we all know
who's responsible Bucky Barnes clearly
contacted the police using Greek
telepathy and managed to stand in the
same position for hours and blocking the
entrance to the crime scene only black
umbrella was allowed at the funeral
cliche this is one of the most awkwardly
worded epitaphs ever go ahead I'll give
you time to read it
see if I just ran a little faster I'd
have been there
super manipulated semi irony let's go
it's my ranee also somehow this guy is
still wracked with guilt about being
unable to stop his mom's murder when he
was a kid but hey whatever fuels your
flash dude was that saying your mother
had about accepting the things you can't
change
yeah I was good someone should really do
something with that a break-in at the
flash Museum
you have your own museum and people are
breaking into it for some reason isn't
this like Bryce Harper having his own
museum already paid for they better with
the taxpayers as usual who by the way
are still paying for Gotham's pro
football stadium and metropolis is
downtown arena Oh know if there was only
some sort of power I had that I could
use to avoid these also he survives this
well flash once again it looks like
you're the bottom and time the top
excuse me what oh no if there was only
some sort of power I knew that my rival
the flash had before I did this I could
have avoided this comeuppance
seriously with all the speed the flash
possesses how is this even a fight how
is he not able to just quickly disarm
these assholes and finish this in five
seconds super fast flash trapped by a
weaponized silly buddy somehow the
adhesive will never completely liquefy
regardless of speed I'm counting on that
what a bunch of bull need i say more
then my life is a small price to pay I
agree Batman X mocking up for sure but
what took this asshole so long to show
up also was he just standing up there
waiting to crash into the window hoping
someone would say something so he could
come crashing through with a retort also
there is a clear front entrance unlocked
and completely wide open due to all the
going down but this dick decides to
smash even more glass to make a grand
entrance the business owners have to buy
Batman skylight insurance in this town
why a Superman you can't Batman take
care of this I wanted to take him so
long show up considering the caliber of
villains who are here right now this is
overkill guys I guess you decided that
since the flash museum already got some
damage you can just destroy anything for
no reason so you could make a dramatic
appearance whoever owns this flash
museums fill you hundreds of thousands
of dollars for being dickheads and
dickhead tax I could try to vaporize the
bombs yes but you'd be vaporizing the
Rogues as well thank God afterthought
Wonder Woman was here to stop Captain
Atom from doing that because nobody else
could have told him it was a bad idea
Diana's right yes Diana's right I too
have a line Batman it's future-tech
difficult to disarm oh thanks for
clarifying not
going to just leave you here Lantern
we're running out of time
how go if only all the other Justice
League assholes and shown up five
minutes ago Blake flashed it we might
not even have this moral dilemma to face
at all also isn't Green Lantern powerful
enough on his own single-handedly to do
a bunch of magic to save the day here at
RIT never looked less powerful than
whenever he teams up with the Justice
League it's sad how Little League of
Canada man to do in this movie I've got
a million microbes eating the bombs
wiring also I understand why they split
up to defuse the bombs so that they
could minimize the damage in case any of
them blew up but Aquaman I'm so
confident this is going to work I don't
understand why they didn't just throw
them all in the water and let the
microbes Hurt Locker the entire crew I'm
wondering did this need to be in space
everyone else is on earth disarming the
bombs these assholes are in space and
why not just in case only Batman in the
bottle and let the bomb guy implode
Batman is super needlessly risking his
life right now to try and be Jeff
Bridges from blown away
in space I love how Aquaman crushes the
bomb but Superman way stronger than that
just covers it with his hands and
weights instead of you know crushing it
that man cuts the bomb off but it
somehow falls through the Green Lantern
bubble you may have minimized the
destruction but the final bomb will
still turn this monument to your ego
into your own tomb why hasn't it gone
off yet why didn't this asshole think of
doing this sooner did he even try
anything else before this looks like
25th century technology is pretty
delicate a centrist keep in mind this is
a cartoon and yet the animators decided
to write an article underneath this
title about mapping the human brain and
it repeats itself later guys I know
you're getting paid with trips to Six
Flags but could you bring it up just a
smidge but the elongated kid murderer
isn't going to catch himself this
nickname somehow caught on this asshole
was about to turn into the flash in
front of other people
Harry are you all right mom Barry's mom
was now alive for reasons we'll find out
about later just happens to be outside
his work so he can know this is a
different timeline immediately also how
the did he know that was his mom I just
Thomas Wayne built the future of his
alternate timeline by giving his 1955
self a sports Almanac that allowed him
to be right about every single sporting
event until 2015
let's be honest you made this movie with
an alternate timeline just so you could
give that man guns just admit it
if recent Batman animated movies are any
indication this just means Batman and
yoyo are going to start booking total
bull get ex machina hi boy
I surrender to you smart this movie
hired Michael B Jordan for the role
cyborg and promptly gave him this kind
of dialogue and then distort it all to
hell you know why we're here that means
war I'm sorry I'm wasting your time with
all this stuff you already know Batman
but this movie is just a little over an
hour and Warner Brothers is spending
tons of money on some King Arthur movie
coming out in four years and 100 million
people die Lance is saying Western
Europe into the ocean another 32 million
slaughter the Amazons invaded the United
Kingdom and the United Kingdom survived
that flowed from Atlantis or are they
just not part of what's in here also us
hey you that's hey can I help you sir
sir Doris it's me this guy takes forever
to realize how it's a wonderful life its
current situation really is irises
husband and daughter show up out of
nowhere at the perfect time to crush
Barry's hopes summer the flash knows
Bruce's secret Batcave entrance or that
Bruce or Alfred was so drunk one night
they dropped a bottle of wine on these
stone steps which then somehow managed
to come to rest on a single step instead
of shattering or at least bouncing off
into the back control portion of the
cave good God how much of an asshole is
Barry nobody knows who you are dude you
walk into the Batcave unannounced and
you don't think that's going to end in a
beating Bruce died and you live you're
his father I did this movie points for
not flashing back to yet another town
when Bruce and his parents left up they
either and ran into tragedy but I'm
still wondering how Thomas Wayne decided
to get the same bug that Bruce did to
become Batman
you're Thomas Wayne man this alternate
reality can go eat a bag of dicks holy
how long is that lasso and how did
alternate Wonder Woman know that this
guy would be running past the Big Ben
clock at this exact moment in time in
order to make this maneuver she's also
one of the most beautiful women I've
ever met I'm so now you need to East
Diana he said worn up he didn't say the
most beautiful woman besides he has the
lasso of truth around his neck so if he
thought you were the hottest I'm sure
he'd tell you dude you never found this
ring until Batman kicked it out of you
you've been in so much denial I'm
absolutely shocked do you have it look
everywhere for this Rick he replicated
the accident that allowed me to tap into
the Speed Force became a criminal
professor zoom this
the exposition is king who really but
his psychosis requires did you know he's
responsible could anyone even Thawne be
that deranged cool Barry Allen dude I
haven't even read one flash comic book
and I can tell you that yes he's that
deranged he said all those bombs at the
beginning of the movie and didn't care
if he died as long as you were there to
die - how stupid is this guy oh those
Chitauri oh no they got venom man this
Justice League movie is a way better
avatar the last airbender adaptation
than The Last Airbender this movie
should have been called literally
anything can happen at any moment Lex
Luthor is using an everyday handgun to
take out these awesome Aquarian guys his
name wasn't Lex Luthor he'd be way dead
by now this discount ant-man sequence
was also not directed by Edgar Wright
I'm right yeah
area one's lightning to strike it and it
does as if lightning could hear and obey
it but at least we know the estimated
location of Aquaman's WMD flashpoint
paradox imagines an alternate timeline
where Barack Obama was actually
president without on top analysts say
without the Batman you have no team what
Batman is the least super-powered hero
ever everyone else in this game is a
metahuman Batman is just a rich guy with
toys and in this alternate reality he's
like 75 years old and is a dickhead your
top analysts are on drugs dude or just
stupid thank you for everything you've
done for this country Victor but as of
now you're relieved of duty also you're
basically a discount Iron Man and fYI
somehow the different timeline on earth
means it's Superman's spaceship crashed
in Metropolis and not Kansas probably
because he was born to destroy the city
one way or another also we could have
started with all this new timeline stuff
way back when Barry first broke the time
barrier near the opening title instead
it's after we've been plunged
confusingly into the new timeline and we
don't know what the hell is going on
maybe there's a good story function for
it like maybe we're supposed to learn
things
only through Barry's perspective which I
respect but hate all at the same time so
wait did Atlantis and the Amazons have
some sort of deal where they decided to
attack Europe around the same time or
did they just randomly do it without
each other's knowledge really confused
about why these factions attacked and
why they started with Western Europe
what's up what's up openly sing in front
of anybody who might have access to this
room which in this case just happens to
be Aquaman's wife
[Music]
Jesus Christ movie this is the r-rated s
pg-13 movie in history versus grieving
mom goes from Martha to Joker and like
everything else in this movie I am just
conclude with some loss it's like every
single idea the writers had went into
the story
somehow I remember things from this
timeline but I can remember my world as
well well that's convenient
you only had to suffer horrible burns
and almost died to gain that ability
though so I guess it was worth it
sooo no forget my timeline and everyone
in it why we try again and you're like
12 hours tops removed from nearly dying
from this experiment and you've
literally just sat up for the first time
to say this how do you even know that
experiment didn't work the first time
can you at least try to run fast for a
moment just to be sure you didn't
already succeed they will pay for what
they did to Queen Meera I told you never
to speak her name seems reasonable yep
they're really doing this experiment
again 12 hours later no idea how he
lived or what to change to fix things
and yet I feel confident they'll succeed
this time only because this movie super
short and we're at the halfway point
already and I sure do love these scenes
they do with Quicksilver so awesome wait
why are we adding us in so the Amazons
apparently have a dinosaur fighting
alongside them which seems really unfair
Wonder Woman's lasso made them spill
their guts literally Felix a
prize-winning journalist Lois Lane
everybody how many gang ex machina czar
in this movie anyway you should be dead
well let's be honest geriatric dad of
Bruce Wayne so should you right just
from aging
I had to make some last-minute
alterations you changed the color of the
suit by moving fast
here's a man so he kept the gun used to
kill his son in a museum-quality case as
it keepsake probably because he knew
some alternate timeline flash would one
day show up and give him a full circle
reason - you said gun oh now I wasn't
able to run as fast as I normally do on
the first try since I got my powers back
what ever will I do then a glowing ring
floated off his finger and shot into
space his ring flew away you're about to
fly a dead alien spaceship and that's
the part you're having trouble believing
yes do you mean to tell me that Superman
ship crashed with this much force and
somehow metropolis survived it
classified information we need it and
you can get it alien was actually just
recently fired by the government so I'm
not sure he can
oh he can still get it no that's awesome
that's actually how I was hoping the
scene was going to go truthfully there's
something there but it's above to my
clean hey why do you even have any
clearance anymore you know if you want
me on your little Suicide Squad
oh wait some kind of hey what the
cyborgs r2d2 bouche at this point I'm
wondering a beast is still powerful at
hacking they might as well have never
fired him in the first place since it
was a meaningless gesture that carried
no actual penalty with you on board we
can save the world from this war this
entire movie keeps overestimating
Batman's value Superman is skinny and
timid and jumpy and have I mentioned how
this movie lost me long ago cuz it did
Superman could have turned out to be
Pepe the prawn from the Muppets and I
wouldn't bat an eye at this point is
that Clark seriously how did changing
the time line change Clark's trajectory
to earth or is this movie saying that
the Kansas thing never happened in the
first place and he conveniently crashed
into Metropolis in both timelines for
this movie later Thawne will tell flash
that Clark's trajectory did change
because of that I think that's true
everything should be changed the point
that everything is unrecognizable here
Superman fresh out of alternate reality
torture prison still to Jesus to ever
carry his own story friends Superman
receives instant powers that every
single iteration of Superman has told me
took practice for him to master also
glad he could take all these bullets at
not die but I wish to my movie would let
this duty to sandwich like pronto
Justice League murder force Superman
close your eyes and that's the origin
story of Cyclops we're really getting to
learn the x-men well in this movie
you're only 1,000 miles from crop zone
c'mon Cerritos Islands 1000 mile Val
does he even have enough fuel for that
wise radio silence demanded so far out
from the target beware my power
well we're a pg-13 movie by God and
we're going to use it when I come from
heroes use those powers to fight to make
the world a better place
hero splaining we have more than Locke
or we have amphibious drawn vehicles you
won't have it much longer surface
dweller that surfaces once we have
Aquaman or Wonder Woman
this war is over as Barry once mentioned
that in his world Aquaman and Wonder
Woman were heroes seems like he's
totally not surprised about this true
2dc form the metahumans try to tackle
each other into buildings hoping that
will work just like the live-action MCU
movies this animated DCU movie gives me
no concept of whose powers are stronger
than who's leaving me no idea as to who
should be winning this fight and a bunch
of kids just turned into punches am and
I am unfazed I am a leaf in the wind
watch how I soar and old Batman died
instantly of 12 different various
ongoing ailments due to old age
including but not limited to liver
damage heart failure Lyme disease and
substances just what you signed up for
right the finale where Shazam tosses
half a skyscraper Wonder Woman and
Batman fires endless bullets it's some
kind of a kind of a bug dude I mean
stuff dreams are made of no take your
team up the right flank this is sort of
where the movie becomes a big Twilight
Breaking Dawn cheek where we see Batman
doing non Batman things and therefore he
is easily shot even though he's been
doing this for 20 years also I'd be
shocked this movie just killed off its
most interesting character in jump-scare
fashion except this movie lost me ages
ago honestly I've been watching Frasier
reruns for the last hour Batman dies Oh
boohoo
did you know Roz was pregnant I won't
stand by while people are well does
Barry see that makes him think we're
there's something about this cafe that
makes me think Ron might be here just an
observation but watching two super fast
people face one another is just about as
amusing and thrilling as watching two
super slow people chase one another in
other words when the talents of the hero
and the villain are the same it makes
for a boring finale
break the sound barrier and there's a
sonic boom you broke the time barrier
flash time boom flash went back to save
his mom just because Thawne stalks him
after they sent him to jail he didn't do
it only was the most emotional about it
he did it because of some goddamn trash
talk Justice League Civil War
Indiana's Atkin seams are just as bad as
any other action movie they're probably
worse because they don't need stunt
doubles or rapid editing to cover up
mistakes they're drawing this just when
you thought this superhero movie
couldn't get any more murdery ex Mach on
a number oh let's say 80 has Superman
coming back to earth way after most of
the battles been fought
just so he can cool bizarro Aquaman at
the last minute shiron friend and if
this wasn't an alternate universe that
we know for a fact is going to get
changed this would be sad oh snap
Canada Manhattan's about to rain fire
and maple syrup on the bad guys asses he
expects me to believe that with the
heart of a lion flash can start running
to break the time barrier even though
his leg is super injured very ah you'll
kill everyone don't splash know exactly
how fast he needs to go to not only
break the time barrier but go back to
the crucial point in time injured flash
manages to catch up to non injured flash
now am I just long hmm well that's my
kind of hello well cemetery boners are
the best boners I would knock off 40
sins if you granted to spider-man right
now
[Music]
everything freezes the difference
between you and me I'm not wearing
hakama
if I were to help you what exactly would
we need guns lots of what have I done
what I done
[Music]
hello Lizzie when I was a little girl
grandma taught me a prayer so I can play
some ball with you where's my dinner
[Music]
waiting is the worst part
you cute you choose me